I lost my keys out Iran it is so bright
so as a lot of you guys know Rosanna has
come out with her own baking line it's
here Michaels this is Michael it's also
at jo-ann fabrics and some Walmart but
today this was the closest thing that I
could find this mini pizza garland not
looking irresponsible
I'm making galaxy clutter look first
poop water slime rose lava fall okay
thank you
[Music]
do you think they'd wear it present
bread I'm so excited so she sent me a
few of these things already those of you
that I do not have and this this is one
of them I don't have the mixing bowl set
I don't have the holidays coming up
Labor Day I missed it miss it
Halloween and mustache mustache that in
a bad joke Andy
[Music]
I had a small mishap try to take a
picture and everything went took a
tumble
I've got fix my hair these are so cute
I'm so thank you here you got them sure
I can always use more icing bags Oh God
Oh Jen we're cooking tonight wait do I
have both of the tips don't have two
tips what's in my hand right here tips
okay
one tip one tip maybe I love this place
I never realized how many things that
Wilton makes and that's a company that
worked his road to make this stuff like
they have so many things it's absolutely
crazy since its fall I need to start
making some fall things so there's lots
of colors here beautiful fashion look at
least sprinkles my god I love this place
so much let's see what else we could see
because I kind of want to make I'm gonna
make a pumpkin pie do you like pop
goodbye are you crazy
pumpkin pie really yeah grandma makes
great pumpkin pie she always makes it
for me as you may feel my whipped cream
off and how one is coming up this cookie
boy our house kit spooky these little
bones oh my god Oh Mike do you see this
yes I'm a little blood oh we're making
that for sure what are you put in it
maybe like a creme brulee
brain mold those are great look on treat
cups you thinking about like little
cupcakes in there maybe guys I'm gonna
have to do what Michaels haul when I get
home because I got so many things for
some future videos I am all ready for
fall now I just need to find the time to
shoot the videos and
what Ice Cube trees such a successful
trip here's my goal oh man basically
everything that I had house a home but
now all of these new items they're not
gonna help Jen's gonna be so upset with
me maybe she can give you her own like
bro section actually I do have one I do
have a row section there you go let's go
home and make something so nice that
everything has been organized I mean
it's all been organized like take a look
at this all of my baking supplies
everything everything has a home but now
we've got a few more additions I'm not
sure I'm gonna put everything look how
many molds I have I've got so many molds
[Music]
what am I gonna make tonight maybe some
little cupcake we enjoy to plan on
playing destiny all night tonight so I'm
thinking that maybe I just make some
simple cupcakes
yes yeah already got everything ready
I'm so excited about these bowls it
what's great is it's all have lids on
them to see if you have like some extra
icing you can just put it in a little
little bowl we'll put it in your fridge
these are so cute
I'm love June 6 2008 teen still good
baby
[Music]
our batter is made and now we've got our
cupcake tins and we're gonna use these
little guys these are rolls little
cupcake brew these actually called lime
ice liners they are I feel so bad like
ruining her packaging but
but you gotta go into the oven we go oh
wow I do not fill 3/4 gosh I need I need
I need no now you're gonna be real
official I'm ready to take the cupcakes
out of the oven looks good to me
[Music]
all right we're gonna make slime on
genna's channel right now and then when
you come back nice these cupcakes in
there we're gonna okay slowly for the
sodium sugar into the glue solution
until you have the right consistency and
all the waters absorb start until you
get the right capacity what's the right
computer well I have like the chunks
there now it makes your blue lips
interpolate when we put in the glitter
Oh where's our decoration you're tall
what are we having white icing yeah the
other problem I had was expired just
your finger okay well I have to make
sure this is what about rusty off trust
across to the system goes well your
dinner honestly I'm an adult
then I can but then I regret it then you
get a bellyache and you're like why
should all to my parents and then I do
it all over again
I was going to use an icing bag and
it I was like I'm lazy
and look at this I did a double-decker
heart okay well here's our cupcake I
think they look very good I'm not gonna
eat them now because I want to have my
dinner first
so we just finished making our cupcakes
and I go and I look at like the
difference between right I don't need to
be me and I'm just saying like your
icing job it's a little rough okay you
bought our meal we got a carb load for
destiny and here's the really sad
reality is that I have to be an adult
tomorrow and go to meetings so I'm not
gonna be able to play all day like I
planned
what that's okay your xbox will be here
set up back to show you guys our gaming
setup I also have a little package to
open which I'll show you in a second but
I got a dime first first I died I just
look good bite it but it's not that good
but you can try it and see
hey hey could you get a napkin oh god I
guess I can get it myself
could you please cuz I don't want to
step except my socks my sauce my socks
have sauce thank you so much you're very
oh god well I think I read my shirt cuz
clearly I can't eat I can't do laundry
I'm basically like a piece of garbage
okay let me tell you what I can do I can
make cupcakes I can play video games
depending upon the game every place in
this shut up I'll come to you with this
book yeah
deb-deb yeah oh gosh I know there is
something destiny related in here
but I don't know what it is we've got
our gaming station set up behind me Oh
what are these one design lab controller
for you or another for a friend
oh my gosh it looks so good now we've
got matching controllers well I just
presented Jenna with her gift and I
realized that my camera stopped
recording so here you go we were gonna
do it again I was gonna leave the room
no I can't fake it for the vlog this is
pretty great thank you so now we have
matching controllers this one I actually
bought the other day this one is one of
the other Xbox lab because you can like
design your own controllers which is
incredible and I wanted a fresh white
super beautiful I might play with this
one because I haven't actually used it
yet what was your inspiration for that
controller Oh me it actually I did say
that and I took a picture of it I
completely forgot I was like I don't
remember what my inspiration was but it
was I was inspired by Maddie and I'm
about ready to play destiny but I got to
show you guys this setup that we have
look at these cords this is staged so
not safe at all going to advanced
warfare xbox that I'm going to my xbox
1s over there how's it going good I
think we need more Xbox or some
downstairs it's installing we well I
accidentally what I think when you
unplugged it I don't think II plugged it
back in
oh I'm playing Gears of War what's
happening over here I'm so excited this
is gonna be fun you might let me get a
headset from downstairs okay because you
can lay out I'm playing as a hunter what
about you
warlock okay I don't like change over
the world this is the first one I
thought you were a hunter but I thought
what but I remember but I don't remember
though well great you would because you
play yours and I played mine
silvery alright we'll see you guys later
Rudeboy destiny and I'm gonna end this
video hopefully I'll post it sometime
soon I'll oh maybe I'm playing the game
and I didn't want it that's realistic
realistic is it guess okay bye pop
here's the problem I'm tired
I know it's sleepy time I are gonna get
my work done before 9 o'clock ok 9 p.m.
what time is it
I literally can't buy my phone let's
guess we'll guess what time you think it
is look at you so you can think for
yourself either you're not we're both in
the middle for you 20 more minutes 20
more minutes we can do it we can wait
I'll see you guys later
I'm either
[Music]